what up though this payroll giovanni
check me on the bootleg care podcast
bye love
yo what's boolaycat podcast we got a
special guest in here
detroit's finest payroll giovanni is
here yeah yeah what up though
what's up man welcome appreciate it man
i just saw you in the bay
um yo help me understand uh uh
what is the love relationship between
the bay area and detroit
it's always been a thing yeah it's been
before me
you know it seems like it's been since
the beginning of time but a lot of
detroit dudes
used to go to get uh get money get back
yeah so
i think the lingo and the in the culture
kind of you know
transfer game like that so we always
been like related like cousins
yeah it feels like it's the detroit has
so much in common like especially you
know like you said like
just there's just always sonically it
just feels like y'all are in the same
pocket kind of when it comes to just the
culture
and yeah like i grew up on the street
lords it was a big
big group in detroit and they used to
have like be legit
too short e40 all of them on the album
so it was like
[ __ ] we started listening to them just
off of that right right right right
so you know and sound sound the same uh
can we talk about i don't know if we're
allowed to talk about the fact that
there's going to be a
reunion album coming oh yeah yeah all
right let's talk about it
so yeah yeah so so this is the first
album in how long or first project
probably about five five six years yeah
yeah yeah we working on it's like ninety
percent done it ain't all the way done
what what what motivated you because
you've been obviously killing it on the
solo
[ __ ] but like what motivated uh the crew
to come back together man
we always been together like we never
broke up well i mean i'm just as far as
just making
you know like getting in the studio and
making that effort to like actually put
a body of work together
i feel like it just had to be the
perfect time i wanted to be organic
because we even got in there and made
music but it just
it seemed forced i don't know i think
everybody had to get some
some real money it was like that's fair
because we first started rapping and it
was like
it was a hobby it wasn't like we was
making music to make money it was just
like let's get on here and talk some
[ __ ]
it was just a time where we just all had
we was all doing good
everyone's doing good yeah let's come
together let's do this let's do it
because we want to not because we have
to
exactly and that's the best music yeah
100 we made a project how does it feel
to be like
you know you you mentioned some of the
guys you grew up listening to but how
does it kind of feel to be
uh you're kind of like low-key like og's
in the city now to like a whole new way
of a detroit artist
man that's a blessing man it's an honor
you know i remember just being young
just watching the ogs like blade and
street lords like eastside cheddar boys
all them on tv like damn
i you know i love to be in that light
they in and
for dudes to compare me to like blade or
street lords you know that's that's an
honor that's like the highest honor in
detroit yeah detroit seems to be
like on fire right now you know just
about time so much i mean listen
detroit's always had
its place in hip-hop i don't feel like
listen i'm from phoenix
we have zero place in hip-hop we've
never had nothing pop off like it's been
rough
my whole life detroit at least you know
going back to the 90s
you could eat you know obviously there
was always royce or eminem and then you
know
dilla and you know i feel like even like
insane clown posse was from around
detroit you know what i'm saying
right so so i feel like y'all i've
always had a presence in hip-hop
but but i feel like right now it feels
like a whole wave you know what i'm
saying
yeah detroit always just had like a
super underground
scene music scene like shooting
artists that's our own hero like this
our tupac that's our hot boys and this
and that
and it seemed like it never got
mainstream like
it just only would go to detroit and
other midwest cities and that was it and
we should be like why like
you know dudes is it's got more money
and more jury than these rappers on tv
so
it should sound good like why the [ __ ]
we don't never you don't get there and
it's just used to be like a
headache like damn what you know what's
crazy detroit and chicago
share two kind of things in my eyes as
far as like there's two sides i feel
like
to like the sonics of the city hip-hop
wise like in detroit there's some of the
illest boom bap traditional
just incredible hip hop that you'll ever
hear and then there's the street side of
the hip-hop scene
right and i feel like chicago is kind of
the same way like chicago's the same
city that bert
chance and kanye and common and you know
what i'm saying but on the other side
there's the drill [ __ ]
like it feels like there's two separate
kind of
sounds and scenes going on in detroit
but they do kind of you know
at times come together but why is that i
mean because you know detroit is a
it's a diverse city right now you got
the street side and you got like the
artsy
freestyle hip-hop side right that
freestyle [ __ ] is serious out there
like it's dudes that go to the halls and
freestyle battle and all of that like
[ __ ] on yeah you'll be like you'll see
like black milk or guilty cinnamon
yeah obviously village yeah you know
what i'm saying but
we all respect each other you know what
i'm saying like it's all love but you
know detroit is a
it's a street orientated city you know
what i'm saying do you feel like
detroit's getting better because i've
heard that like uh the dude owns the
cavs is like buying up a bunch of real
estate and cleaning [ __ ] up like
and my boy lives in troy he does radio
out in detroit at uh at the bounce but
he's he was saying like ever since he's
been there he feels like the city's
getting built back up like it's starting
to look better like how do you feel
about
where detroit is right now i feel like
it's doing a little better
i feel like it you know our downtown for
sure look better because you
like i would hear you could buy like
[ __ ] hundred dollar houses in detroit
no i'm not a hundred dollars
or some crazy [ __ ] like that right yeah
yeah
i see that [ __ ] on the internet that's
gonna be a fixer-upper yeah but you
could like
40 000 into it forty thousand dollars
you know you put
into a house and you know you're gonna
have a nice crib
how much really i i heard when we were
in uh an empire in the bay i heard you
mention uh
uh you would talk we we got a game
coming out called out of pocket but you
you mentioned real estate are you are
you pretty uh tapped in on the real
estate side
i'm getting into it like my first
experience in the real estate
it was a horror story so i kind of like
backed away from it like what happened
man i bought a house and uh it was a
raggedy ass house and it just
it just went bad but i had it you bought
one of those houses i had bad intentions
with it
i'm gonna put it like oh okay okay you
know i had a whole plan to do with it it
just didn't go right so i just kind of
left it alone
i was like damn i basically wasted like
ten thousand dollars on this [ __ ]
it could have been worse yeah yeah yeah
ten grand but my man is one of my my
close homeboys he like
owned like in their half her
neighborhood i'm gonna be seeing what
he'd be doing i'll just be learning from
him just getting gained from him so
you're starting to get into that
yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah um
can you take me back because i remember
when you guys signed with
jeezy i was thinking like because i i
had heard of you guys and heard some of
your stuff
i was thinking like wow like dope like
some of the street [ __ ] out of detroit
was getting like a real mainstream look
at the time and it obviously seemed like
it didn't work out
it didn't work out you know what i'm
saying what do you think what went wrong
with with the cte situation because i
want to say you guys
came into cte like right after
freddie gibbs had left yeah um became a
yg
yeah it was like the yg dope yeah yeah
so it was like around that same era cte
yeah like what went wrong i don't know
man
i don't i think we wasn't ready for real
that was new to us like we was used to
just being independent we really wasn't
taking that rap [ __ ] serious like that
like we kind of stumbled upon it like
yeah i was still like one foot out yeah
we just following our path like okay now
we gotta do this do that
when we got there it was kind of like
okay who's your pr who's your man we
like
[ __ ] we ain't got none of that [ __ ] what
is that all right what does that mean we
was learning as we were going right so
you know it was a whole type of
different experience for us
and the detroit sound really wasn't
popping like that at the time they kind
of wanted us on them uh
to attract them them trapped me right
right
right right that [ __ ] just sounded
horrible like just didn't mesh
yeah they like man they sound like some
old cash money [ __ ] what y'all doing why
the beat so fast i ain't really
understand it like that
damn i feel like the timing wasn't good
timing just wasn't good
not at all i mean because the yg thing
worked out yeah yg [ __ ] worked out i
watched him make that whole
first hour was that like was there like
a cause i feel like there was like a
weird period of time where like
there was like all the old guys from cte
had left like you know what i'm saying
and then you guys were like the new
regime and the old guys didn't have good
things to say about it
about it yeah freddie gibbs yeah they're
good
yeah was aaron [ __ ] jeezy out did you
guys ever feel like
like you kind of had to like have
jeezy's back and a lot of that
man i'm here to get my money feed my
family man i ain't
i ain't inherited no beefs man that's
smart man yeah
unless it's serious of course of course
some music [ __ ] no
i'm i'm chilling what was something that
you learned though
from that experience or maybe from geezy
that you because you know you've been
doing
independently a lot of boss [ __ ] in the
last you know seven eight years so like
what's something you took from that
experience or from gz directly that
you've kind of applied to
your oh man her career now his work
ethic like dude just
non-stop like and that was like my first
time ever being in the studio
to like seven in the morning oh yeah
that's those are the nights yeah like i
never used to do that i come in the
studio
two three hours and i'm gone do what you
gotta do get home so when i was with him
i'm like
why are we doing this like we're in
studio till [ __ ] daylight like i'm
[ __ ] interested i did that [ __ ]
every day and i'm like man this dude is
a multi-millionaire so we gotta
put in double the work right so i
started applying that just going to the
studio every day
yo um talk about because when was the
first project with carter was that 2016
i don't want to say 16 or 15. i ain't
sure
what what inspired you to do uh first of
all
get ricardo and i feel like uh you kind
of
you know have been fluent some other
stuff happening in hip-hop right now but
but but i feel like you and carto
definitely came together and
and uh did your thing man with both of
those projects but
how did that happen really cheesy
cheesy yeah jeezy um he had flew me out
to atlanta and we was working on a
project what uh
it was gonna be me cardo and yg and
jeezy he was going to be a group
really it was all cardo produced and we
made a whole project
i was holding all right so you cardo yg
and jeezy
yeah and that was supposed to be like a
super it was called like paid in full or
something like that
and you guys did a whole project whole
project we had beats from warren g
das dillinger what dj quick
and cardo did like all other beats and
it was a hard project
but for some reason it never saw the day
of light yeah but that's where me and
cardo
found our niche like we found our pocket
you know a lot of them nights in them
studios together wow
how many uh how many songs did you guys
do for that project i think we had about
a good
twelve about ten twelve last album yeah
we all had solo songs and uh group
songs it was hard damn
when would that see the day of light if
ever i don't know who has that
jeezy jeezy's gotta show it's up to him
he got on the hard drive
it's on a hard drive just sitting
somewhere yeah that [ __ ] man classic wow
that sounds like that's like one of them
albums it's like gonna be folklore for
now every
yeah that [ __ ] was special i was excited
about that why
yeah are you and yg still keeping
contact i ain't talk to yg in a minute
but that's you know
it's still love for sure no 100 percent
man yeah why do you
do um and then obviously just like we
were talking about the
the scene in detroit detroit seems like
it's always been like historically like
super divided depending on what side
you're from like what side of town
you're from
yeah um there seems to be like
less of that recently like people
working together [ __ ] like that like is
that
is that you know obviously you and pz
got a whole album together like
yeah um how's the detroit scene right
now you feel like as far as just like
the camaraderie and you know it feels
like there's more
people moving together as opposed to i
feel like it's good like we're in a good
space it ain't
you know it ain't really much beef going
on like everybody really just
putting that [ __ ] to the side and
getting their money with this music [ __ ]
cause
that's where the bag is and then that
big sean cipher was
[ __ ] crazy yeah because i i don't
think uh i don't
i cause i talked to soda baby and he had
like no idea that like tt grizzly was
going to be on there and like
oh yeah you know like like he put just
everyone i don't think everyone knew did
you know that like i had an idea
everybody you know is going to be on
there but i get along with everybody i
ain't
i don't care yeah i wasn't like i don't
put me on a song with him like
how how big of a deal is that like to
have like sean do that you know man sean
been showing us love from day one
of course like when he didn't even have
to he been shouting us out on songs and
reaching out doing songs with us so i
got i got a lot of respect for big sean
like he been embracing us day one
remember you said it's about time though
look sean's been popping for a long time
yeah yeah for sure long ass time for
sure man it's crazy because like
i feel like his album with uh
detroit too was like uh it's
his best part his best body of work so
far man sean cole he's been cold like
that though
he used to record at the studio he used
to record that before he i think before
he signed with kanye oh wow yeah like he
been taking that rap [ __ ] seriously yeah
it's crazy to think his first album came
out 10 years ago he's celebrating the
10-year anniversary and i just was like
[ __ ] i'm
old man old as hell i remember when that
[ __ ] first came out
like him and mike posner running around
doing mixtapes and [ __ ] and
yeah it's crazy so you i know you have
so the the uh dope boy cash out album
has come in and then
you're you got a new solo album yeah
working on it
which is is how how close is that to
being done
about 90 95 percent weight on a couple
verses
people and i heard you talking about it
in san francisco a bit kind of break
down like the concept of the album
like it's called giovanni's way it's
something i've been
like promoting for like five six five
years every time i was about to come out
with it something else
presented itself like cardo or something
right right and i just get sidetracked
but i'm finally about to drop it
it's basically like everything that led
me to this point i'm basically just
speaking on all of that all my
experiences everything
what features are already on the project
uh
t grizzly and peasy cash dial
uh i think that's it right now i'm off
to detroit
yeah yeah i'm i'm reaching out to other
people too but if you have a show i want
to detroit on here be
if if you had to pick someone from the
bay to do a whole project with who would
it be
somebody from the bay yeah man i [ __ ]
with a lot of bay area i feel like you
larry june on the car don't say larry's
larry jones
you know we got a whole project called
game related i didn't know that me
uh my man's hbk and larry june all cardo
beats
all carter beats yeah we just like threw
it out there like it wasn't really
promoted none of that
who else like uh from the bay would you
kind of consider to be like
you know you're in the bay a lot like
who's somebody who you would kind of
consider to be
you know more than a a hip-hop affiliate
everyone [ __ ] with each other you know
what i'm saying but there's very few
friends
i [ __ ] with a lot of dudes on the bay
man filthy rich of course yeah of course
uh
e40 be legit a lot of og
you know og cash you know what i'm
saying i'm getting hip to the younger
dudes though yeah there's a whole
there's a lot going on
yeah the base like detroit i feel like
there's like so much new [ __ ] coming out
and it's just like i can't even keep up
with it that's how detroit is like i'll
be like
oh what is this like i see everybody
singing in the club i'm like oh i'm
supposed to know what this [ __ ] is like
what is this
you know it's crazy it's crazy yeah um
what what about like
you know in terms of like let's say 10
years from now man
what do you like like where do you want
your legacy to stand at you still want
to be rapping do you still want to
like do you want to kind of have some
other [ __ ] going on at that point in
time i want to be a ceo man
i want to just fall back you know kind
of play the background just have a bunch
of successful artists out there
to sign an artist yeah yeah that's most
definitely like my next thing i'm about
to get into
but you know who's done a good job of
that is i think the
i always give got to give him his
promise but yo god he's been like yeah
yo god
so amazing he he raised the bar like he
raised the bar everything he touched
it's crazy yeah yeah and like you know i
think what's important about that
is like you got to actually want whoever
you're signing to be bigger than you
if you're going to be an artist who
signs other artists like you you have to
put your ego
to the side and like genuinely want that
person to be bigger than you ever worked
because it make your legacy bigger
100 like all these people came from up
under him like
you know that's that make your legacy
huge yeah i make it go forever
100 man yeah how did you react
to um just a pandemic detroit
was it like super close down there yeah
it was shut down for a minute
it was shut down for a long ass time but
everybody was bawling
everybody's getting money everybody was
getting that money man it was it was
like
[ __ ] the 80s it was crazy that that
that [ __ ] ppp money [ __ ] yeah
booming yeah i was
i went to the uh we got a mall called
somerset it's like the high-end mall
it was man [ __ ] was like a zoo it was
just people in there just fighting and
shooting and robbing i'm like god damn
like these people in this market never
been in this one they like
yeah no i know i have like close friends
of mine who have hit serious
six-figure government licks during the
pandemic
it's it's wild yeah it's just
you have a dude young dude it's like tax
season times
100 but it's like everyone's got it it's
it's insane man
yeah dudes like serious as hell like i'm
about to get a ferrari next week
like no like are you sure that's a good
idea that's what's up be careful
yeah you might want to be careful that
might be a red flag yeah
yeah you might want to you know get one
of them ten thousand dollar houses
yeah yeah they ain't thinking about that
yeah it's it's wild yo
how how how does like this you know
cause i'm a big sports guy and obviously
there's
detroit is is a big sports city y'all
got out all the [ __ ] teams
um but how how like how does the
you know the pistons the lions tigers
like coincide with the culture in the
city like
because i feel like uh you know some
cities will see like quavo on the
[ __ ]
on the hardwood at the hawks game [ __ ]
like that i feel like the pistons are
trash
oh don't do us like i mean i mean they
are
you guys got the number one pick in the
draft that doesn't mean you're good i
mean i'm not
i'm not a big sports dude right right
but i just mean like support do the
players like tap in with the scene out
there oh yeah yeah i just did something
with the pistons just did something with
them
we're coming with some whole [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying so you did
something
what are you doing with the pistons
talking about i ain't gonna really you
know i don't think i could speak of it
yet but you know
they come with like their own show
through the years was there like a
player on the pistons or the lines that
like you ended up like like really
connected with the [ __ ] with
that really kind of embraced what was
going on in detroit because i feel like
the players be on the pistons ain't had
a franchise player in a minute they'd be
it they'd be in there like
year two years and they out okay well
nine
nobody for real nah i just ran into them
here and there right
now it's been a while since it was ben
wallace and uh rip hamilton and
that's actually who i ran into i ran
into ben wallace at a club
the legends solo you know was this
recently
it was about probably about four years
ago that's still crazy
yeah ben wallace at the club yeah that's
like
yeah upscale club you know gotta be a
nice place yeah
yeah what do you think is the biggest
misconception about people giovanni
that i'm an [ __ ] and i mean cause i
don't talk much like if i don't know you
i don't
i'm not gonna talk to you i'm not gonna
introduce myself to you
that's just some detroit [ __ ] like you
know you kind of be standoffish but
i'm a cool you know laid back cat man is
there anything uh
that you can do to like get you because
i feel like you're super chill
right we see t grizzly doing twitch and
playing games and [ __ ] and like we can
see a whole nother left like side of t
grizzly that nobody ever would know
existed right
is there anything like that that you
might you know get into whether it's
doing some podcasting [ __ ] or
or i mean i'm hoping for it you know
i'm open for it i was actually thinking
about doing my own podcast or something
just to
share my thoughts and things like yeah
that shouldn't be up know what i
feel about this and feel about that but
i'd be like man the world's so sensitive
you get you might get cancer they gonna
hang you
or they're gonna love you hey i feel
like boozy is like cancel proof oh you
know boosie don't give up
he said the most craziest [ __ ] and
everyone still loves him yeah
he don't give a [ __ ] man yeah i [ __ ]
with boosie too
hey when we would always hear like you
know coming up in in
as fans of hip-hop like always would
hear about trick trick and the no-fly
zone thing right and then there's the
um historical instance of ross not being
allowed to perform
[Music]
which was a real thing that happened
yeah people who don't know
i don't know the details right right
right but but
that that no-fly zone thing like is it's
like it's like almost like hip-hop
folklore
where it's like if you feel like when
you go to detroit you gotta check in
with somebody
right is that something that's like real
or is it more like
is it uh trick trick most definitely is
real do i know that no trick trick is
super
like daughter trick drinking ghoul squad
ain't
i'm doing for no games man they've been
they've been doing that [ __ ] since the
90s
i just did a song with trick trick too
that's a trick trick man he just had the
uh
uh hip-hop uncovered on fx he actually
got a show uh
sunday a big show you know what's up oh
out there in detroit yeah i'm hoping i
can make it too
that'd be big yeah not i thought it was
dope they did that effect series about
yeah yeah that was hard i like that that
was [ __ ] super dope yeah
yeah do you think eminem um does enough
for like the scene in detroit like he
never left
he still lives there right but do you
think like he's done enough like to kind
of help put on other detroit artists
uh i feel like he didn't put on some
people you know he put on trick trick
for real
yeah yeah like you know proof like proof
was real like
crazy you know what i'm saying
yeah you know but you know the street
side
they feel like you know they don't know
him and this and that what's also like
the i don't know many people probably on
the street side like that i know
personally that are like listen to
eminem right
you know i know a lot we grew up
listening to them though like when you
first came out yeah
like we was like yeah let's do hard we
just happiness from the d
and then damn dudes new proof and then
he did a [ __ ] movie called eight mile
like based in the city you know what i'm
saying
that people was just like oh what is
this like that was it was it accurate at
all
it didn't really represent like the
detroit i come from is it more than
white trash
detroit it represents like the freestyle
battle culture like it's
detroit a diverse city you know what i'm
saying like it's different
different sides to that [ __ ] who are
your like top two or three favorite
uh new artists out of detroit that
you're that you're just a fan of
uh the new artists man it's a lot of
them man
so many of them uh i [ __ ] with tay b
um let me see
baby money uh
i know a lot of them man they they like
from my area so like you mean like new
like younger yeah just like you know
there's a lot of new like we
we're talking about the bay there's so
much new [ __ ] going on it's like
there's so many man yeah i [ __ ] with tay
being baby money i'll be
you know i'll be banging that [ __ ] all
right my producer cook is a die hard fan
cook you get one question appreciate
that too man
one question from the producer cook
man um
any new projectile cargo coming out yeah
yeah i mean carter always working man we
were actually working on big boston
three
yeah and then so like big bosses
you guys had to put the one and a half
up because of samples or
yeah some weird label record label [ __ ]
i
never even listened to it actually right
i know some of the beats are like this
yeah
game of life yeah it's like it was
cringing for me like
why did they do this [ __ ] you know yeah
i guess it was sample
reasons yeah so mercedes got that real
fan [ __ ] to ask
my life is like one of my favorite songs
i appreciate that you saw the short
movie
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have
underwear that's right you can get your
odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you these are
chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
have it check out save twenty percent
yo appreciate you for pulling up
appreciate your so what's the timeline
on the album
so you say you know we just talked about
three different new albums
yeah man hopefully uh giovanni's way be
out here by like
august but don't hold me to that so
that'll be the first thing we're waiting
for
yeah okay then uh then doughboy's cash
out and i got a project with zaytoven
i'm working on two
oh [ __ ] and zaytoven coming with a whole
other bag on this [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] it sounds different so you got
four projects on the way i probably got
more than that for real
any other collab projects with any other
artists like full collab projects
not with no artists i got something with
different producers though hello
yeah me and halibut of course me and
hello and uh
the olympics okay yeah of course yeah my
man's knoxville
was is there an uh you know you and pz
linked up for a project is there another
artist in detroit that that you would
love to do just as
just a full-on collab album with
i mean i'm open to anything for real but
me and peas are actually talking about
doing another project too
you know who's on fi i think they've
been just killing [ __ ] ever since they
they they
really went straight independent and
they were independent before but uh i
swear vezo been on his [ __ ] lately
oh yeah yeah he stayed matching on the
gas he's been killing it yeah
i know he was on that motown situation
and you know they kind of stalled him
out a little but like
that's
that's how detroit artists work though
like we better independent with our own
freedom there it is man
look payroll giovanni appreciate you for
pulling up four or five or seven albums
coming soon
yeah about five six of them there it is
movies all that
hopefully we hear this yg gz yeah we're
gonna
get into existence man the next time i
see the full album there it is
perfect for the show appreciate you man